esta vez nos dicen que este cuadrado es
una unidad cuadrada y nos preguntan cuál
es el área del rectángulo a entonces lo
primero que nos dicen es que cada uno de
estos pequeños cuadritos equivale a una
unidad cuadrada así que aquí tenemos una
unidad cuadrada y aquí otra y por acá
otra y con ello nos piden encontrar el
área del rectángulo a y recuerda que el
área es el espacio que cubre hombre una
figura entonces en este caso nos
preguntan cuánto espacio cubre este
rectángulo y cuántas unidades cuadradas
cubre el rectángulo y una forma de
responderlo es contando los cuadritos
que cubren el problema es que el
rectángulo está por encima de nuestras
unidades cuadradas así que una buena
idea sería pintarlas de nuevo si el
rectángulo no deja
la cuadrícula que hay abajo entonces
vamos a dibujar la de nuevo vamos a
dibujar de nuevo esta cuadrícula vamos a
dibujar todos estos cuadros ok vamos a
dibujar más por acá y más por acá y
ahora sí ya podemos contarlos y puedes
ver que tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 cuadrados es decir tenemos 12
unidades cuadradas entonces este
rectángulo cubre 12 unidades cuadradas
déjame notar la unidad
cuadradas
trad
esa es su área 12 unidades cuadradas
ahora bien esta no es la única forma en
la que podemos resolver esto también
existe otra forma para resolver este
mismo problema y otra forma es observar
este rectángulo am y decir mira el lado
de arriba de este rectángulo
tiene una longitud de 4 unidades mira
una dos tres cuatro eso quiere decir que
si dibujamos la primera fila de este
rectángulo am va a tener cuatro unidades
cuadradas una 2
3 por aquí y 4 y ahora podemos ver por
acá este lado y preguntarnos cuántas
filas de cuatro unidades tenemos bueno
tenemos una por aquí tenemos otra por
aquí y otra hasta abajo eso quiere decir
que tenemos tres de ellas
aquí tenemos tres filas de cuatro
unidades cuadradas cada fila la primera
fila es esta por aquí tenemos una
segunda fila y por aquí una tercera fila
entonces tenemos tres filas y cada una
de esas filas tiene cuatro unidades
cuadradas tres por cuatro unidades
cuadradas hay cuatro unidades cuadradas
hasta arriba cuatro en medio y cuatro
abajo por lo tanto tenemos tres veces
cuatro unidades cuadradas lo que nos da
un total de 2 unidades cuadradas o
inclusive podemos ir más allá y pensarlo
de la siguiente manera podemos decir
bueno aquí tenemos una columna observa
la esta es una columna y esta columna
tiene tres unidades cuadradas
aquí las podemos ver porque la longitud
de este lado es 3 tenemos tres unidades
cuadradas en esta columna y cuántas de
estas columnas de tres unidades
cuadradas tenemos en este rectángulo
bueno pues observa que tenemos cuatro
aquí tenemos la segunda la tercera y la
cuarta y eso es porque la longitud de
acá arriba es cuatro por lo tanto
podemos decir en esta ocasión que
tenemos cuatro columnas de tres unidades
cuadradas y lo podemos ver aquí una aquí
tenemos la segunda por aquí tenemos la
tercera
y bueno por acá tenemos la cuarta
entonces no importa como resuelvas esto
ya sea contando todos los cuadritos como
lo hicimos al principio o ya sea
multiplicando las longitudes de los
lados en este caso 3 y 4 en ambos casos
llegamos a que esto es 12 unidades
cuadradas el área de este rectángulo es
de 2 unidades cuadradas porque ese
rectángulo cubren 12 unidades cuadradas